In today's video,
we're seeing what happens
if we run cinnamon,
a highly flammable powder,
through fire at high speeds
using our sandblaster.
[Music]
Guys, not too long ago,
we did a video showing
you some cool things you
can do with cinnamon,
throwing it to a fire,
and how it not only burns,
but makes them
really cool sparks.
A lot of people commented to see
if we could actually put
cinnamon in our DIY sandblaster,
and shoot it through a flame.
So we decided not only
that we're going to try that,
but we've also got
a couple other types
of flammable powder
that were also going to try
throwing in our sandblaster.
And then, we thought we
might scale it up as well.
Some of you may remember our
fire extinguisher flamethrower.
We're going to fill
it with cinnamon.
And the other two powders.
And everything else.
This is just a really
high volume of powder at once,
and we want to see how it works.
Here's the basic idea.
We have three different
highly flammable powders.
We are going to put those
into our DIY sandblaster,
shoot them through a fire,
and see what happens.
So I took up our sand blasted
into a compressor,
fill it with cinnamon,
maybe build the fire
up a little more,
and then shoot it through,
see what it's going to do.
Okay, this point,
we have air flow,
and I'm keeping the whole
thing turned upside down
so that the cinnamon
is not flowing into it.
So it should just be air.
I've got it on fairly
low PSI at the moment.
Let's just give
a blast in the fire.
This is going
to be extra oxygen,
should help the fire
grow a little bit.
[Music]
That looks amazing.
Let's add a little bit
more lighter fluid,
because if you haven't seen
that other video,
to get that effect
from the cinnamon,
that spark effect,
it really works better
if it goes through
the open flames of the top.
With sugar and coffee creamer,
sometimes works better
if you throw it down
onto the fire.
But with cinnamon,
you really want to go
through the flames.
Okay.
Air compressor with cinnamon.
Come on, cinnamon.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Okay, that's about
what I thought might happen.
While it's blowing through,
the volume of cinnamon
is pretty low,
and the speed is quite high.
So I think it's just flying
right through without having
a chance to catch on fire.
But you may have seen,
when this sandblaster goes,
air travels through this pipe.
There's a hole down
in the bottom of this pipe,
and the cinnamon should be
feeding down through that.
The Bernoulli effect
of the fast-moving air
through the tube sucks some
of the cinnamon into the tube.
In the process however,
it does add a little bit
of pressure into the bottle
itself that's full of cinnamon.
And when all of the fast-moving
air is turned off,
because I release the trigger,
they're still pressure
in that bottle,
and that squeezes
it a little bit,
and we have a higher volume,
but much slower amount
of cinnamon that then comes out
as that stream of thick cinnamon
that you were seeing before.
So there's the high volume,
and then when I let go,
there's this secondary slower,
but larger quantity of cinnamon,
and that I think is
what's actually catching well.
[Music]
Yeah.
Oh, that looks so cool.
That really look like a cinnamon
flamethrower right there.
We're trying this again.
We've turned up the pressure.
Before, we're running
at about 25 psi.
Now we're running at about 80.
Ow.
Why would you?
I was just trying to clean
the extra cinnamon off my hand.
Ready?
Ready.
[Music]
Yes.
That was like our best one yet.
Oh, I love that.
[Music]
Is it pretty much out again?
That is how fast we
are going through cinnamon.
And this higher pressure,
those, those spurts
like this bottle was half full.
It goes through--
It's super fine so it's not--
It doesn't last nearly
as long as like a salt
or a courser grit.
Yeah.
[Music]
Here it goes.
What?
That was a 10-foot
purple flamethrower.
Holy cow!
[Music]
Yes!
>> Okay.
>> That was beautiful.
[Music]
Coffee creamer.
This stuff is fun.
Flares up nicely.
I've got high hopes for this.
Oh, this is going
to be beautiful.
Yes.
Yes, it will.
Fill her up.
It also pours a lot more easily
than the powdered sugar,
or cinnamon.
Yum?
Mm-hmm.
[Music]
That's a really good flame.
But it seems...
I think it's so flammable
that is just all burns.
Way too fast.
Yeah, so that's short.
[Music]
That's a really good flame.
That looks, it's just
like straight-up Dragonfire,
like it goes straight
and concentrated,
but it all burns up.
It seems a lot more intense
than the other one.
I think it does.
>> Yeah.
>> The other ones,
I'm like I'm not too afraid
to be that close,
so long as you're not standing
in the dust cloud
of the cinnamon
or the powdered sugar,
then you're pretty safe.
This one, I would not want
to be close to.
All right, so we
are mixing all three now,
because we want to know
what's gonna happen.
Maybe we'll get purple sparks
and intense fire.
Oh, yes.
That'll be neat.
[Music]
The cinnamon, of course,
has the strongest flavor,
but you get some
good sugar, and...
That's why it's delicious.
Yeah.
[Music]
I don't really
see the purple,
but it's got a good flame,
and it's got sparks
from the cinnamon.
That's fun.
I like it.
[Music]
Whoa. Okay.
Nice.
Now, we want to try scaling
this up a little bit,
maybe not in terms of pressure,
but definitely in
terms of volume.
So we're going to be using
our good ol' flame thrower
made out of a fire extinguisher.
It's got a Schrader valve on it
so we can add pressure
with a bike pump.
We're just going
to add powder in here.
We're going to start
out with a mixture
that's mostly powdered sugar
with some cinnamon
coffee creamer in it.
And I think we'll also try one
that's just cinnamon to see
how much of a spray
and sparks we get off of that.
[Music]
That is delicious.
This one's mostly
powdered sugar.
Little bit of coffee creamer
and cinnamon in it.
[Music]
3, 2, 1.
That was amazing.
This is my new
favorite toy ever.
Man, that worked well.
Oh my gosh.
That works so well.
That is my favorite.
Woo!
>> That was--
>> Do it again.
Well, it's empty.
No.
We have to refill now.
[Music]
I think we got double
the distance that we had
with our small-scale one.
So it was mostly powdered sugar.
So you saw we got
some good purple.
Yes, that was gorgeous.
I like that.
And then, we got a little bit
of a sparkling in there
from the cinnamon.
The coffee creamer
may have helped a little bit
with some more orange
or keeping it all together.
That looked really cool,
but I do want to try one
that's just cinnamon.
That is a fire extinguisher
full of cinnamon.
I've never been so happy.
Which is a weird thing to say.
Not sure if anyone's
ever said that before.
For anyone who gets this,
today is January 30th, 2019,
and a very certain game is
currently at my house waiting
for me to play.
This is my only consolation.
Here we go.
About 99% cinnamon.
Little bits of residue
from the other powders in there.
And go for it.
So much sparks.
Yes!
I don't think it burned
quite as well,
but the sparks were unreal.
That was crazy.
That was just like
a giant sparkly fireball.
I don't really care.
That's-- Ahh, that was amazing.
That's really fun.
I really liked that.
[Music]
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
This box up here
at the top will take you
to our latest video.
That box the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit this bomb in the middle
to subscribe to the club,
so you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.